hello John mother it's Kiki madam I got
two questions for you actually thing
morning
what do we sound like
can you describe it and then the other
question I thought I can't think a
real-time chip and never left I'm
curious what you think space malleable
thank you
hi Kiki you want to know what did the
early universe sound like well this has
actually been simulated I have a friend
his name is mark whittle whi ttae if you
look up mark Whittle big bang on Google
you will find his webpage and it has a
recording you could listen to of the
sound of the Big Bang of course it's
accelerated quite a lot so you can
listen to the expanding universe in a
few seconds but it sounds like a roaring
noise with a pitch that diminishes
rapidly with time as the universe
expands the things go slower so you can
listen to a simulated Big Bang on the
Internet it's a remarkable simulation
that he's done the other thing you
wanted to know is what does outer space
smell like was this not a question of
what does the space station smell like
because that of course smells like what
did we take with us but if you want to
know what is the outer space before
stars and planets exist I smell like
then you would want to go to different
places and find out what are the
chemicals that are there so places like
the Orion Nebula which you can see with
your own eyes in the sword of Orion our
places where there are abundances of
molecules of many kinds well over a
hundred organic molecules have been
discovered in space and some of them you
would be able to smell if you had enough
of them so just imagine that that you
could actually compress those a
molecules from outer space into some air
so you could actually have a chance to
live and smell them you would smell
ammonia it would smell chemical
compounds like benzene like many are
what we call aromatic hydrocarbons I
think it would smell like a chemistry
lab there would be sulfurous ones it
would smell bad there would be some that
are poisonous like carbon monoxide which
is extremely abundant so you
wouldn't want to smell it for very long
but anyway you would smell the
constituents of interstellar chemistry
and there are any remarkable surprises
out there about that people imagine that
those chemicals are responsible for the
presence of carbon and the possibility
for life here on earth so it matters a
lot to us about that interstellar
chemistry